every geeks dream and a great reason to
keep driving your car it's episode 21 of
IMG here's a picture of Darth Prime and
here's Barbie as a homicidal sociopath
not terrible enough for you then check
out this example of bad parenting what's
this kid freaking out about oh well
here's a trick to make you look buffer
and here are sad drawings of Kirby
summer
trippy summer ghosts and some are
violent but some just aren't even the
right color these books with pages
folded to spell words were cool a couple
weeks ago but this shelf of books tells
us more but if you prefer emoticons Kira
Rathbone uses typewriters to print
symbols on the paper to make elaborate
works of art now chances are you're
using your eyes to see these images but
up close your eyes look like sand dunes
your iris is a freaky structure made of
fibers and cells attached to muscle so
use them to witness the most confusingly
badass birthday cake ever or if you
don't have a sweet tooth try this pizza
topped with pizzas topped with more
pizzas now funny tennis faces
in the olden days things were still
pretty cool dogs pulled cars pandas took
pictures men shot children and played
tennis on biplanes and cigarettes were
for to historical upskirt IMG has shown
you a lot of cool things made with Legos
and today I bring you Stephen Hawking oh
and here's Ellen Page playing the lying
down game I'm in love on facebook.com /
Vsauce gaming you guys rule antonio
showed us a 3d Apple laptop and Glenn
proved that The Lion King is real peace
wait who's that and an unfortunate jump
location so I'll leave you with some
advice if you want to look less lonely
buy this t-shirt and if you want the
awesomest videos on the web check out
this site get it be sure to check out
wacky gamers new a street fighter puppet
show and subscribe to wacky gamer comedy
for more let me know below in the
comments what's the best joke you
recently heard I can't wait to read them
and hey as always thanks for watching